Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
DEADLINE
just reported that Marvel and Sony
are actually thinking about doing Tobey
Maguire's Spider-Man four movie.
It almost sounds unbelievable.
Technically, they'd be finishing it
because they got pretty far
along in pre-production
before they canceled that movie
and rebooted into Andrew Garfield.
Spider-Man.
we actually have a bunch of footage
from Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man four,
because they got so far
along in pre-production.
I'll play it during this video
Because it sounds so unbelievable.
We know they're making Tom Holland's
Spider-Man four all explained what I think
this probably means and why
they'd be talking about this right now
when we know that they're mostly focused
on the main MCU Spider-Man movies.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
The Secret Invasion Episode six finales
this week that we have Ahsoka
episodes coming in a couple of weeks
and Loki season two episodes coming later
this year.
I'll be doing videos for
Everything is going to be super crazy.
But you probably saw the Spider-Man
for Tobey Maguire news in your beads.
It started with Thomas Haden Church, who
plays Sam Raimi's version of The Sandman.
He was just back in Spider-Man.
No way home with the other Sinister six
villains as part of that multiverse plot.
He was asked about Spider-Man four
during an interview recently,
and it was picked up by a more reliable
trade publication like DEADLINE,
making it sound like
it might actually be a thing,
Normally
when stuff like this gets reported by fan
sites, it's a little easier to dismiss
when trade publications,
which are supposed
to be a little more legit, pick it up.
You actually turn your head like, Wait
a minute, what is this actually happening?
he had said that he'd heard from industry
insiders, like the people that actually
work on these movies,
not fans that just report on the movies
that Spider-Man, for which Tobey Maguire
was a thing that they were trying to do
in, wanted to campaign for Spot.
And since his character was still alive
at the end of the Tobey Maguire,
Spider-Man three ran after Spider-Man.
No way home came out.
Tobey Maguire was actually talking about
when he signed on for the movie,
he asked the writers of that
they'll not to give away
too much of his character's backstory
after the events of Spider-Man three,
because they were saving that
for a potential future movie.
At some point,
that would have basically been
what happened to him
during the events of Spider-Man four.
And beyond that.
he didn't say he wanted to come back.
But I think at the time
a lot of us just assumed
that meant Avengers six Secret Wars
because it was a big multiverse movie.
I don't want to say
like close the chapter, but revisit
and have a certain resolution and
and just join in this like,
loving, creative spirit.
even if Sam Raimi, Marvel and Sony
want to make
his Spider-Man four movie,
we know that they're mostly focused
on Tom Holland's Spider-Man four
and future sequels to that in the MCU.
so at least
right now, unless something changes,
I wouldn't hold your breath on them doing.
Tobey Maguire Spider-Man four
is like a completely separate solo movie,
but we have gotten most of the footage
from that movie
that they had already completed.
This is like a really big first look
The reason this happened
is because they'd already been
making the movie
when it was canceled back in the day.
And there's a statute of limitations,
like the people that posted
all this stuff were like,
We're not going to get sued.
Sony is not going to sue us.
Sam Raimi had finished the story.
They had a bunch of new suits
that were made ready to go.
Also explain what was supposed to happen
in the movie as well, because we know
basically what the plot was going to be.
but the first big thing
that you probably saw posted in your feeds
that leaked out was John Malkovich's
vulture suit.
he was going to play
a version of The Vulture.
And they were going to say
that he was called the Vulture
because nothing was left of his victims
except for the bones.
Like that's how hardcore
he was going to be during the movie.
he would have still been a technology
based vulture like MCU,
Michael Keaton's vulture.
But it would have been
a much more organic vibe.
Like the comic book
version of the character his daughter.
Get this was going to be played
by Angelina Jolie,
who would have also been a version
of Vulture rest during the movie.
this is a small part of the final fight.
Like, I have the entire video,
but it just goes on and on.
So you kind of get the idea.
Okay. Yes.
But what was supposed to happen
with Spider-Man four
is that it looked like
they were going to lose their Uncle Ben
cameos.
The actor
that played him
wasn't going to be available
for the movie,
and they might
also have lost Kirsten Dunst,
and they couldn't bring back
James Franco because they killed him off
during Spider-Man three.
So because they didn't have Harry Osborn
and they didn't have Mary Jane,
they were going to introduce
Felicia Hardy, Black Cat.
The Vulture
was going to be the main villain
and he was going to lead a Sinister
Six team the Lizard Doctor crew.
Connors from the previous Spider-Man films
was going to turn evil as the Lizard.
There would be a small romance
arc with Felicia Hardy's Black Cat.
She would flip side, she'd be a little bit
evil, little bit good.
During the movie.
the Vulture would be responsible
for creating electro
so that character would happen.
you can see that
they reused a lot of these ideas
for Andrew Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man
like they did full on Lizard.
Then they did Electro.
They did a bit of a team up
in Amazing Spider-Man two.
but they were also going to do Mysterio,
which they're finally doing now.
But it was going to be Bruce Campbell.
So it was going to be a slightly older
version of Quentin Beck.
going to try and make it more intimate.
Find the heart of what made Spider-Man
great originally in the comic books.
I'm going to try and return
to the Central core
of the character that I fell in love with,
and that way I try and make it better.
They had done a little bit
of pre-production.
Those were actual storyboards
from the movie.
and this is a portion of the script
that I'll read here.
So this is only a couple pages,
but it sets the background
for what was going on
during Spider-Man four.
So the mysterious plot of Spider-Man
four becomes known
while I'm reading from this,
I'll cobble together an edit with images
from Tobey Maguire and Spider-Man films.
So it makes a little more sense.
We open up in the sky.
A feather falls to the ground
just as it does a slew of bank robbers
pour out as they look up at Spider-Man,
swinging down gracefully, landing
in a spider like position.
He beats down the criminals as the cops
arrive and the whip head swings
into the alleyway, he removes his mask
revealing to us to be Peter Parker.
Parker enters the daily Bugle to reveal
that JJ has been removed as Ed in Adrian.
Oh Toomes has taken his place.
The Vulture Toomes is a hardened,
bold and scared man
who also doesn't have a sense of humor.
By night, Toomes turns into the vulture
and begins to rob many banks
across the city By morning,
the headline spreads across the city.
quick backstory.
John Malkovich was going to play
The Vulture in this movie.
So picture John Malkovich
when you're thinking of Adrian Toomes.
Spider-Man
and begins to investigate the case
with a utility belt
that is equipped with a mini crime case.
He yanks out a small magnifying glass and
starts out over the scene of the crime.
He notices the feather, he picks it up.
Spider-Man swings into the ESU University
at the Ding of midnight,
scrolling over the feather
using a DNA scanner machine, Parker
finds out that the DNA belongs to Adrian
Toomes.
The next day.
Mary Jane calls
Peter for lunch to meet her real father.
Peter arrives at the Love Kitchen
with a suit clearly not fit for him.
Accompanied with a stash of roses,
He drops them at the sight of her father,
Adrian Toomes.
Both Peter and Toomes shake hands.
This being an awkward scene,
We move our cut to Peter
and MJ's new penthouse apartment.
The two are arguing over
the idea that the man can't be trusted
and that, in fact, he is the vulture.
Mary Jane leaves in anger.
so they're already changing the comics
quite a bit.
Like Adrian Toomes
Vulture is not Mary Jane's father.
But then in the next part of the story.
Adrian Toomes winds up causing an accident
at Electro Corp and creates
the Max Dylan version of electro.
Then he slowly puts together
his Sinister Six team.
So it would have been John Malkovich
leading a version of that team.
the way they were going to explain
the Spider-Man Black Cat bromance
during the events of Spider-Man four
is that Mary Jane was going to leave
Peter Parker and move to Los Angeles
to become an actress.
So he was going to be single.
Then a little bit of time goes by
and he catches Felicia Hardy, black
cat committing a crime.
they wind up in bed together,
that begins their relationship.
And then she winds up trying to help him
take down the Sinister Six.
I don't really know
if people would have been willing
to accept that love triangle
with Black Cat and Mary Jane
after they spent so much time
developing that Mary Jane relationship
and all the drama and all the weird stuff
that happened during Spider-Man three,
What ended up happening,
though, is the big third act twist is this
The black cat
was going to secretly betray Spider-Man
because Adrian Toombs had been holding her
sister hostage.
So it would have been this
big double cross
she yanks the rug out from under him
but then triple crosses
the vulture later and helps Spider-Man
take him down.
they wind up
winning by the end of the movie.
But then Peter apologizes to Aunt
May for all these problems
he's been causing, and he finds out
that Mary Jane still wants to be with him
in Los Angeles.
So remember in Spider-Man two,
when he threw the costume in the trash
right out of the comic books, Spider-Man
No more.
He does the same thing off the Brooklyn
Bridge.
He throws the mask off the Brooklyn
Bridge,
then goes to Los Angeles
to be with Mary Jane.
the reason why that movie didn't get made
is that Sam Raimi felt like
they never cracked the script.
They went through three different writers.
So by the time
it was getting ready to shoot,
he told Amy Pascal,
who's been there, Spider-Man person
producer at Sony for a long time,
that he didn't want to have
another Spider-Man
three situation
and make a disappointing movie.
so he told Amy Pascal to go ahead
and reboot the Spider-Man character
like they'd already been planning to do.
And that's where you get to Amazing
Spider-Man with Andrew Garfield,
which they announced just a little while
after that.
what an interesting thought
that they had actually been planning
on rebooting Spider-Man
as far back as Spider-Man three.
So they had been developing Spider-Man
for a while.
They were planning on rolling out
Andrew Garfield, Amazing Spider-Man.
I think Sony was just waiting to see
if Sam Raimi was just going to unfurl
some masterpiece of Spider-Man
four, like, Oh, okay, we'll make this
instead of doing Andrew Garfield.
But they wanted to have Andrew Garfield
waiting in the wings
just in case that didn't work out,
which obviously did not in
Sam Raimi later actually reacted
to Tom Holland's recasting too.
he was actually surprisingly happy
with the idea to take the character
back to high school and do a much younger
version of Spider-Man.
And I'm really glad that Marvel
is taking it to high school.
I think that's going to be refreshing
and just like my favorite
of the Spider-Man comic books
and I have a lot of faith
that they really know their stuff.
The funny thing.
Watching that
Sam Raimi already came back to do Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
So it's already come full circle
with all the Easter eggs.
Spider-Man came back to the MCU.
Sam Raimi came back to direct
more Marvel movies.
Tobey Maguire said when he came back, one
of his big notes when they were writing
all of his scenes in Spider-Man
No Way Home, is that they shouldn't
go into too much detail
about what had happened to his Spider-Man
after the events of Spider-Man
three, this way.
They're only a couple of light references
because now that he was back,
there was a chance
they could actually do some of that.
In a new story.
We do know that he eventually married
Mary Jane.
They had a daughter.
That's basically his version
of Mayday Parker from the comics
and currently in his universe,
he continues to act as Spider-Man,
saving people.
his daughter
sounded like she was very young.
So he hasn't come close
to retiring or anything like that
or passing the mantle on to her.
Let me know
in the comments, though, which movie
do you want Tobey Maguire to come back in?
Sony has all kinds of crossover plans,
obviously, but Avengers six secret wars in
the MCU is probably pretty likely
but that was essentially
what Andrew Garfield was talking about
in the deleted scenes that they put
in the extended edition of Spider-Man
No Way Home.
When they released it in theaters,
there was a scene of him saying,
We should do this again sometime.
I'll get your phone
number after the big battle.
doing it again some time
was basically them doing it again
during Avengers six Secret Wars.
and Big reminder, the Secret Invasion
Episode six finale is this week.
I'll post my video for that
next. On Wednesday.
we might even get a Loki Season
two trailer video this week.
If they do wind up releasing it.
Of course we'll do a video for
it is going to be crazy.
We'll get more footage for that during
the also episodes later in August to.
Click here for my secret Invasion
finale video and click here
for all my Comic-Con trailer videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!